did you know that you can convert a
Karass model to a tensor flow estimator
it'll give you a whole host of options
around distributed training and scaling
stay tuned to find out
welcome to cloudy eye adventures where
we explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we are going to
prepare a Karass model for running at
scale by converting it to a tensor flow
estimator so we have a Karass model easy
to define clear to read and friendly to
maintain but it doesn't do so good with
scaling up to larger data sets or
running across many machines
luckily Karis and tensorflow have some
fantastic interoperability features what
we want to do is convert our Kerris
model to a tensor flow estimator which
comes with the distributed training
built in that's our ticket to solving
our scaling challenges plus it makes it
easy to do models serving once our
training is complete the function that
we are interested in is called model to
estimator and I've taken the notebook we
started with in the previous episode and
updated it with new code to convert our
Kerris model to a tensor flow estimator
we'll also take a look at how to export
your Karis model as is once training is
complete along with the tensor flow
model let's switch over now to the
Kaggle notebook and dive into the code
so here we are back in our Kegel colonel
with our fashion M NIST data set this
code should look eminently familiar
we're gonna load up numpy pandas
tensorflow and matplotlib and we're
going to pull in our data set with
pandas read in those csv files and take
a peek at the first couple of rows we
can see that the first column is our
label column and all our pixels are all
the rest of the columns to the right
I've got this handy pre-processing
function which takes our data frame and
pulls out the values for the features
and the labels and then we can save them
directly into our variables like train
features train labels test features and
test labels then we'll go ahead and do
our one hot encoding this is exactly the
same as we saw in our previous episode
we're gonna convert those labels which
were numbers to labels that are arrays
of n 10 for our 10 different possible
labels then we'll run our train we got
our training parameters and we'll create
our Kerris model this is exactly the
same code and we saw to create a Karass
model before and once we have that
created we can run model dot fit
identical to what we saw in the previous
episode once we have our model fit we
can go ahead and test it and now we get
to the interesting stuff our conversion
how do we convert our Kerris model to
tensorflow estimator we'll use model to
estimator this function takes a couple
of different arguments but in our case
we're just going to pass it the one
pointer to our model to the argument
caressed model and that will convert our
Kerris model into a tensorflow
estimator once we have our tensorflow
estimator in hand we can do everything
we would normally do with a tensorflow
estimator in this case I've chosen to go
ahead and train it right we should train
our estimator and see what we can
achieve in terms of accuracy and
performance so if we want to do that
first we need to think about how do we
architect our input function and the big
question there is for our features we
need a label for those features what do
we call it when we're coming from Charis
we don't really get to name it ourselves
we have to run model dot input names and
this is the input names of the Charis
model not the tensorflow model those
names are copied over and so we can look
at our Kerris model and see that in this
case it's called dense three input
and when we pull it out we use that
variable input name right which points
to dents three input as our key for our
features so once we have that set up we
can do pretty much the same as what
we're used to seeing with tensorflow
estimator training we'll have our
feature columns will in this case I'm
going to rename our TF classifier is
just classifier and now we can train and
since we use the correct input names we
can do this without any errors if you
don't use the right input names you will
get errors so be sure to get that input
name out now we can run evaluate and set
up that evaluate input function you'll
notice that we'll need to use that input
name once again here so really good idea
to save that off to a variable another
thing to notice here is that we used the
one hot labels in the tensor flow
training and evaluation just like we did
in Karis now when we ran this model in
pure tensor flow in the past with
fashion immunised we were able to use
the not one hot encoded labels we could
just use the labels that were five and
seven and nine in this case because we
took the model directly from Charis and
moved it to tensorflow that conversion
also resulted in the model expecting one
hot encoded labels and so you'll need to
make sure you use the same labels as you
did in Karis in practice this ends up
being really convenient because you can
just use the same variables and the same
arrays that you used before now we can
see that the evaluation is completed in
this case we got to 86% and then Karis I
think we got something similar and we
can see here yeah 85% the accuracies
will vary depending on a number of
different factors ranging from the
random initialization state how my
computer is feeling on a given day
things like that now that we have our
models trained in both Kerris and
tensorflow
let's take a brief look at how we would
export these models out into the file
system caris models are very
straightforward to export you just call
model dot save and give it a name and it
will export it in the hdf5 format on the
tester flow side exporting our model
requires the use of the export saved
model function this function takes two
arguments one is a path to export it to
and secondly a serving input receiver
function which for short is often just
called a serving function tensorflow has
a utility to help you build that serving
function and that takes as an argument
this mapping of the input shape and type
this helps the model know what kind of
inputs to expect so once we run our
export saved model on our tensorflow
model we can see where it was exported
to and we can see that tensorflow
exports models as a file and a folder
called variables so for convenience I
also like to zip it up or tar it up so
that it's easy to download and then on
the other side once you download it you
can unzip it with tar as well so that's
kind of what's involved with taking a
Karass model we've taken that converted
to a tensile estimator and then exported
that tensile flow estimator we've
managed to do all of this without
actually creating a tensor flow
estimator from scratch we've gone all
the way from taking a Karass model
training it converting it to a tensor
flow of estimator training that and then
exporting the two of them and we'll be
able to use those exported files in
future episodes to do more interesting
things getting distributed training
using tensor flow estimators is an easy
one line adjustment to your Kerris model
so now you have the best of both worlds
easy to read caris model creation syntax
along with distributed training via
tensor flow estimators thanks for
watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures
and if you enjoyed it please like it and
subscribe to get all the latest episodes
right when they come out for now
remember that all you need to get
distributed training working with your
Kerris model is to use model - estimator